What question is how our happiness and
habits related.
And I've been researching and writing
and thinking and talking to people about
happiness for years.
And what I started to notice was that
habits play a really important role in
happiness because a lot of times when I
would talk to people,
there was some big happiness challenge
in their life that I realized was
actually related to some core habit.
And it wasn't that they didn't think or
know that if they got more sleep,
they feel better or that if they didn't
spend so much time on the Internet
during work,
they'd be more productive or whatever.
They had identified the change that they
want to make,
but for some reason they weren't able to
stick to that change.
They weren't able to make that change
happen no matter how much they wanted
to,
they could see that there was a
happiness gain out there,
but they weren't able to translate into
action.
And that got me very focused on the
issue of habit change.
So how is it that we specifically change
a habit so that we can make these
desires,
these aims that are so pressing in our
lives?
How can we translate it into real
action,
real change in our everyday lives?
Because the fact is,
you know,
there's,
for most of us,
there's a lot of low hanging fruit.
There's a lot of things just part of our
ordinary day thinks that don't take a
lot of time,
energy,
or money,
that if we could do them,
they would make us happier.
But we really have to get ourselves to
actually follow through.
And so that's where habits come into
play.
Because habits are the thing that allow
you to make those changes and just put
them on automatic pilot.
They're just part of your everyday life
and they make you happy.